so I've got two parallel lines so that's
the first line right over there and then
the second line right over here let me
denote that these are parallel these are
parallel lines to do that a little bit
neater parallel lines and then let me
draw a transversal so a line that
intersects both of these parallel lines
so something like that and now let's say
that we are told let's say we're told
that this angle right over here this
angle right over here is 9x plus 88 and
this is in degrees and we're also told
that this angle right over here is 6x
plus 180 - once again in degrees so my
goal here and my question for you is can
we figure out what these angles actually
are given that these are parallel lines
and this is a transversal line I
encourage you to pause this video and
try this on your own well the key here
to realize the key here to realize is
that these all right over here are
related by the fact that this is their
form from a transversal intersecting
parallel lines and we know for example
that this angle corresponds to this
angle right over here they're going to
be congruent angles and so this is 6x
plus 180 - this is also going to be 6x
plus 180 - and then that helps us
realize that this blue angle and this
orange angle are actually going to be
supplementary they're going to add up to
180 degrees because put together when
you make them adjacent their outer rays
form a line right over here so we know
that 6x + 180 - plus 9x plus 9x plus 88
is going to be equal to 180 degrees is
going to be equal to 180 degrees and now
we just have to simplify this thing so
6x plus 9x is going to give us 15 X and
then we have 180 - plus 88 let's see 180
- +8 would get us to 190 and then we
another eighty gets us to 270 plus 270
is equal to 180 is equal to 180 if we
subtract 270 from both sides we get 15 X
is equal to negative 90 negative 90 and
now we can divide both sides by 15
divide both sides by 15 and we get X is
equal to what is this let's see 6 times
15 is that 60 plus 30 is 90 so this is X
is going to be equal to negative 6 so so
far we've made a lot of progress we
figured out what X is equal to X is
equal to negative 6 but we still haven't
figured out what these angles are equal
to so this angle right over here 9x plus
88 this is going to be equal to 9 times
negative 6 times negative 6 plus 88 9
times negative 6 is negative 54 negative
50 4 plus 88 let me write this down
before I make a mistake negative 54 plus
88 is going to be let's see to go from
50 88 minus 54 will give us 34 degrees
so this is equal to 34 and it's in
degrees so this orange angle right over
here is 34 degrees the blue angle the
blue angle is going to be 180 minus that
but we can verify that by actually
evaluating 6x + 180 - so this is going
to be equal to 6 times negative 6 is
negative 36 plus 180 - so this is going
to be equal to let's see it's 1 let's
see if I subtract the 6 first I get to
176 so this is gets us to 146 degrees
and you can verify 146 plus 34 is equal
to 180 degrees 146 plus 34 is equal to
180 degrees and we could also figure out
the other angles from this as well we
know that this if this is if this is 34
degrees and this must be 34 degrees as
well those are opposite angles this
angle also corresponds to this angle so
it must also be 34 degrees which is
opposite to this
angle which is going to be 34 degrees
similarly if this one right over here is
146 degrees we already know that this
one is going to be 146 this one's going
to be 146 since its opposite and that's
going to be 146 degrees as well